so we're going to start off this video
with a challenge
you have two seconds to find 10 year old
me
in this photo
one
two
if you said this guy
you're wrong
it's this guy
i have the same haircut pretty much
and almost the same
pose
anyway
this photo was taken in
2004
i was playing against susan polgar
in a simultaneous exhibition
uh and susan polgar was playing against
i think like 30 to 40
opponents at the same time
and the way it worked is she would just
go around in
a kind of a circle
more like a rectangle of tables
she would come by my board i would make
my move
and
it's a very impressive feat
for a single player to play so many
players at once
and uh we played a really interesting
game which i found
recently
in my old score sheets
and i took a photo of it so this was my
my score sheet and my handwriting back
in 2004
and we played uh we played a really
fascinating game which i thought i would
share
in this video
i didn't know it at the time but susan
would go on to be my
college chess coach
um i attended webster university in 2015
and yeah she was my coach there for a
couple years so i think at the end of
the video i'll share an updated photo of
me and her from just a few months ago
but i did find another photo
it was a year before we played in the
simul
this was taken in 2003
may 23rd
and this is the first
photo
i have
i guess me and her so before we get into
the chess i do want to thank
a new sponsor to today's video
and to do that i'm going to move over to
the other camera
thank you to
morningbro wait morningbrew for
sponsoring today's video
if you haven't heard of them they are a
completely free
email newsletter
that focuses on business technology
current events finance
and it's a great way just to stay
informed and educated about what's going
on in the world i signed up to them a
month ago and i learned something new
every day
and they even recently featured abi
manumishra who became the youngest grand
master ever
at the age of 12. i think it's a much
healthier way of starting the day than
mindlessly browsing reddit
or social media i know who you are
so
it only takes 15 seconds to sign up link
is down below and i really hope it can
bring as much value to you as it's
brought to me
and with that let's get back to the
chess
so in this game i was playing black
and actually if we look more closely at
the photo
every single player was playing black uh
against susan in the simul this is
usually how symbols work the simular
gets to choose their color and usually
they just
play white in all the games
while other players have to
play black and eat pizza i guess
so uh susan opened with
the reti opening or the reity
uh one night f3
and
at the time i was rated 1500 so i had a
basic understanding of
opening principles i had some like
general opening repertoire
but i wasn't super booked up compared to
the way i am today
and the interesting thing about this
game is i
played well i would still play today for
the first
uh like six to seven moves
we uh we transposed into a queen's
gambit declined c4 e6
knight c3 bishop e7
and this is still my same repertoire
very classical
queen's gambit declined
um actually more recently i've been
playing a6
but for many years the course of being
rated over 2200 bishop e7 has been
my main move of choice one of the main
lines in this position
uh susan played most common move bishop
g5
and after castling
e3
this is a very standard position
in the queen's gambit where white has
maintained the tension
and is just focusing to develop very
naturally get the pieces into play
and in this position black has a few
options
h6 i believe is a main line if we check
with opening theory
um h6 bishop h4 and b6
is a so-called tartak hour defense
very solid line has been around for many
many years
the move i played is also very natural
knight b to d7
uh just developing still staying
flexible
black can still choose to play b6 or c5
or h6
um
i will say when i played this game i
didn't really know so much specific
theory
and that's one of the big differences
between
how i play chess today
and how i played back when i was rated
1500
is these days i'm much more
thoroughly prepared in the opening
and i'll just share
one
tidbit of opening preparation
if i had this position
today i would most likely play a6 this
is one of my more favorite pat lines
and in some of the variations after a6
i'm prepared very very deeply
like through 20 moves deep so i'll just
share one example line to give an
illustration of how
how thorough my preparation can be
the point of a6 is to take on c4
play b5 and c5 and expand on the queen
side fee encounter the bishop
so it's very typical for white to take
here
after takes bishop d3
the main line continues knight bd7
castling rook e8 queen c2
knight to f8
and it's common for white to go for this
minority attack with b4 b5
i would play c6 let's say b4
and then
from this position even though
both players are out of the opening both
developed and castled and going into the
middle game
uh my my preparation continues
and there's a cool plan here to play
knight g6 bishop d6 and h6 to get the
bishop pair
and the critical line okay starts with
knight g6
let's say white goes for minority attack
bishop d6
e5
takes takes and now h6 forcing white to
trade off one of the bishops
if bishop takes g6 we take on g5
and the main line bishop takes f6
we take back
takes takes
and now one of the reasons why i'm
showing all of this is to share
what used to be a really cool novelty
and it's a pretty rare and lesser known
line but it's a cool idea for black if
white plays the most common move e4
trying to exploit the fact that the
queen and bishop are very forkable
either by the pawn
or if takes and the knight hits both
pieces
and uh c6 is also weak if white were to
play e4 there's a really cool response
knight f4
and this is all based on like engine
preparation
run move 18
um and it's still pretty much my my
modern opening preparation
and the point is if white goes for the
fork
black calmly slides over with the queen
oh no my bishop
but oh no white's king side is actually
in really big danger here
if white were to play the move g3
i believe it's already force mate after
takes
takes and bishop h3
and good luck stopping queen g2
um
so a better defense for white here is to
play knight e1
defending the pawn
but after rook takes e1
we're still threatening mate white
doesn't have time to take back
and uh white can still save himself with
f3
but after takes
let's say bishop takes
and queen e6
this is pretty much the extent of my
preparation in
least this variation where black is
going to be winning upon and having a
slightly better position um and all of
this is computer approved
so um i just wanted to show that as
inspiration for perhaps the players who
struggle playing against d4
and maybe want something
a bit deeper and more thorough
especially against the queen's gambit
which is such a common opening these
days
but let's go back to the game
and we'll see
how
i actually struggled in the opening
given my lack of preparation
and just not knowing what to do
going into the middle game so knight g7
it's a very fine natural move
susan plays
rook to c1 which is actually very
typical in these queen's gambit
positions
whenever there's tension between the d
and c pawns
white generally doesn't want to develop
the bishop
allowing black to take and then white
will lose a tempo so it's useful for
white to put the rook
on a file which is likely to open
and wait for black to take so i can take
back in one move with the bishop
so
i think at this point i already didn't
quite know what to do i went ahead and
played h6
which is a fine move i think these days
i would be more inclined still to play
a6 maybe even b6
but after h6
bishop to f4
i played c6
um trying to solidify the center
unfortunately for black the main
drawback in this position
is this bishop
is really really sad
given that all these pawns aren't like
squares
um
it's hard to
to be active as black with uh it's just
such a passive lightsweight bishop and
this did eventually hurt me later in the
game
so
okay susan plays bishop d3
i play rook e8
castling
and now i go for knight f8 so
i am being ultra solid
the problem is my pieces don't really
have
great harmony
and it's hard to be active as black
um because i committed to h6
i'm not actually
really having the idea of knight g6
given bishop takes g6
would just damage my my kingside pawn
structure if i wanted to go for this
plan i should have kept my pawn back on
h7 so the knight would be better
supported
and we can see after 95
it would actually be very nice if my
pawn were back so knight g6 would
initiate some trades
but in this position i am just getting
a little bit squeezed
so i play the move trying to trade off
some pieces
knight six to d7
and
i did have the understanding that when
one side is low on space that side does
want to trade minor pieces so they can
breathe a bit more easily
and in this case i'm just trying to
trade off uh the knights unfortunately
after 97
white already has some really cool
practical possibilities
and
here white started with taking on d5
i took back
and then when susan came to
make her next move
she actually took a lot of time
and i do remember her getting to this
position
and taking at least a minute
before making her next move
and this made me really excited because
there were like 30 to 40 people in the
room and susan stopped at my board
taking a lot of time
and i thought i was doing really well
because i'm making
a chess grandmaster think i thought okay
i'm putting her under pressure
but in reality she was thinking how to
completely tear me apart
and uh this is
basically what ended up happening
starting with her next move
what's really unexpected
is knight takes d5
now this is a move which
i think for a lot of players like they
wouldn't even consider making
given that
as white you just assume that d5 is
defended black is solid
but the point of knight takes g5
is after i take back
white has another very surprising move
and for this i'll pose a question to the
viewers
quite a move
what was susan's idea how can white
justify the sacrifice
and get a very strong attack in this
position feel free to pause the video if
you don't see it already
okay so before i show the move
i do want to talk about how you actually
find the tactic here
is you have to realize that
the black queen
is almost trapped
and white has the idea of eventually
playing bishop c7
to trap the queen
and even going back to this position
this is a
an idea that should be under white's
radar so after takes takes the
continuation for white
is yet another knight sacrifice
knight takes f7
and now we can see black is under major
major pressure
given if king takes f7
oh no my queen
and the queen would just be trapped
and you might say that okay queen takes
c7 rook takes c7 black has three minor
pieces for the queen there's still some
fight left
but given that black's minor pieces
are
very much undeveloped the king is out in
the open moves like queen h5 are coming
hitting the king hitting the pawn
this would be very very unpleasant to
defend as black
so
after my f7 i knew i was in trouble and
of course i saw the idea of bishop c7
and i did manage to find the best move
here is queen
to b6
saving the queen
not recapturing the knight but keep in
mind that black is
up a piece because white did sacrifice
on d5
so white has two pawns
or
having given away the knights
now
susan did not take her
foot off the gas
played another
very aggressive move
knight takes h6
insisting the knight
should be sacrificed
here i don't really have much of a
choice i went ahead and took it
and after queen h5 we reach a situation
where
white is down two pieces
white's down two nights but has a very
very vicious attack
both bishops
along with the queen
are pointing at several different
targets
h6 is hanging d5 is hanging
also my rook is hanging on e8
and the interesting thing about this
position
is that if we turn on the engine
the engine will favor black his engine
will find the most precise
defensive moves
and argue that black is just up material
but for a human to defend this it's very
very difficult and i would have had to
play
a bunch of computer moves to survive
here
so
i did play actually the best move in
this position knight f6
both uh defending the rook and the pawn
and attacking the queen
very multi-purpose move
um i did allow queen takes h6
and now here
i made uh
the mistake of moving back
which actually looks natural like this
is a move i think even today i would
consider
given that i'm trying to trade queens
get rid of white's main attacking piece
but what i should have done in this
position
is keep my knight here defending some of
the key squares
and bring my queen back
and
if we look at this
position with engine
it will say
about minus 1.5 to minus 2
that's not to say black is
out of danger yet
and white uh white would have ways to
continue attacking like bishop e5 f4
that would still be a very messy
position
however let me show what happened in the
game
after
knight six to d7
uh queen h5
hitting the rook hitting the pawn we
actually repeated for a move
knight went back to f6 i was hoping for
repetition but
of course white turned it down queen g5
and now after king h8
this is where i really began to feel the
pain
i should have played king f7
this would have offered me better
chances at defending
but to play king f7 would have
required a lot of courage given that the
king just looks so exploitable here the
rook is able to come in
and at the time i thought my king
was better on hh8 just hiding in the
corner i was thinking about playing the
h7 soon
um the problem is after bishop e5
i get in a situation where i'm
completely stuck because my knight's
tied down completely pinned my king has
nowhere to go all the squares around the
king are controlled by white
and it's very very difficult to escape
the bind
in this position
so i went ahead i play queen e6 here
and now susan plays a very powerful move
upon f4
reinforcing the bishop
maybe allowing the rook lift in future
cases
also making it so if i want to trade
queens with queen g4 queen diggs g5 but
pawn could recapture and there would be
even more pressure against my knight
so f4 was a very nice way of
just increasing the kingside attack
um i went ahead and played queen f7
just trying to turtle up
still uh enjoying the fact i'm
up to pieces
but that was really the only thing to
like about my position
was after queen h6 knight h7
and bishop g6
this is where
i start losing back my material
advantage
i went ahead and played queen g8
really really trying to just hug my king
tightly with uh with my pieces
then rook c7
and white's
pieces are coming in from all directions
both of my knights are now pinned my
bishop is basically pinned to
the knight on h7
if we look black is almost completely
paralyzed here it's very very difficult
to find a move
and
it was incredible play by uh by susan
who
at the same time was playing dozens of
other games
and was able to produce such a
masterpiece
against such an innocent child so i
tried here i played bishop e6 finally
developing my light squared bishop
unfortunately
um
actually this this does allow maiden 3
which
white missed in the game
uh susan found uh
another kind of brutal way of finishing
me off with rook takes e7
but if you do want to try and find the
checkmate in three which susan pogar
missed
feel free to pause the video
but i will go ahead and show
white can
take on f6
and after
i have to take back there's rook h7
queen h7
this would have finished the game bit
more efficiently
but what happened the game
uh was also just completely destructive
after rook
e7 rookie 7 bishop f6
we reached a position where i had to
play
the really sad move rook g7
and this is not the definition of fun at
least for black this is really fun for
white though
and it's it's actually a very aesthetic
setup where i'm just completely pinned
down and tied down
if my queen ever moves away then i get
mated with queen h7
and
okay susan just
ended my pain by winning material takes
on h7
takes on g7
takes on e6
and got a position where white is up
or pawns
and still has a mating attack
after i played one more move queen h4
rook c7 i resigned in this position
given that white is either mating me
like this
or mating me like if king h8 there's
queen here and then mate
so i threw in the towel
and uh ended up losing after
31 moves
which uh
i was okay about i wasn't too upset
given
the way in which i lost
uh the mistakes i made in this game were
a bit more subtle like there wasn't one
clear blunder which caused me to lose
it was just the fact that i played very
passive in the opening
i gave my a very strong opponent a
tactical opportunity which
uh she jumped on and
then
i didn't find the computer-like moves to
defend
so it's cool game i hope you guys enjoy
that
and before i end the video i want to
share
one uh last photo
i know i shared
this one earlier
in 2003
a few months ago in may
susan polgar actually retired from being
the
webster university chess coach
and had a retirement party
and at that party
we uh we recreated
the photo from 2003
um about 18 years later
and
uh yeah i i grew up a little bit
she's still sitting in a chair
probably a slightly different chair that
was really cool to have played her in
the simul and then attended webster
to be coached by her
and
she's still doing amazing things in the
chess world
so
again i hope you guys enjoyed that video
and if you liked it feel free to leave a
comment subscribe and stay tuned for
more content